今天我們來聊一個有點出乎意料的案例，來自英國的新創公司 HexSeed。他們做的事情是把碳捕捉後的廢棄物，變成鑽石塗層，然後用來幫 AI 數據中心散熱。
鑽石塗層？聽起來有點像科幻片。而且還是用廢棄物做的？這真的撐得久嗎？成本會不會很高，最後沒人要用？
其實這點我有仔細看，他們剛拿到超過 70 萬歐元的早期資金。投資方有 Carbon13、Net Zero Technology Centre 和 Vento Ventures。這還解鎖了 Innovate UK 的一筆夥伴補助金。代表這模式至少初步被市場看好。
嗯，有資金進來是好事。但從廢棄物變鑽石，然後應用在這麼高科技的數據中心，這中間的技術門檻和成本控制，怎麼說呢，感覺有點遙遠。一般公司大概很難模仿。
這也是讓我覺得有趣的地方。CEO Mark Tandy 說，AI 數據中心未來會消耗英國電網很大一部分的電力，而其中很大比例的能量都因為熱損耗掉了。他們就是看到了這個痛點。
解決散熱問題當然重要。但為什麼偏偏是鑽石？還有，不是說鑽石很貴嗎？怎麼能用在數據中心這種需要大規模應用的地方？
鑽石確實是目前已知最好的導熱材料。但是，傳統上製造鑽石需要非常高的溫度，那會直接損壞半導體設備。所以，關鍵點不在於鑽石本身，而是他們「低溫」製作鑽石塗層的技術。
低溫？所以這是他們的核心技術？這怎麼做到的？難道有什麼魔法嗎？
他們跟布里斯托大學的教授 Paul May 和 Martin Kuball 合作。Paul May 是鑽石材料專家，Martin Kuball 則是半導體和熱管理專家。HexSeed 開發了一種「低碳、低溫」的微波電漿製程。
微波電漿？這聽起來就非常專業。所以，他們能把鑽石塗層直接應用到已經完成的氮化鎵（GaN）設備上，而且不會損壞？
對，就是這樣。Mark Tandy 和共同創辦人 Dr Leonardo Santoni、Dr Michael Glerum 創立了這家公司，目標就是讓這個技術商業化。他們說，這樣可以讓 GaN 設備運行更久，也更省電。
這樣看來，這家公司不只解決了 AI 數據中心的散熱問題，還讓碳捕獲的廢棄物有了高價值去處。這點確實滿厲害的。那如果我們是一般創業者或主管，能從中學到什麼？
我覺得，就是「跨領域整合」的思維。環境科技的碳捕獲，材料科學的鑽石塗層，再加上高科技產業的 AI 數據中心需求，看似不相關的三個領域，卻被他們巧妙地連結起來。
確實，很多時候我們都習慣在自己的專業領域裡打轉。像這樣把「廢棄物即資源」的概念，和產業的痛點結合，這點是值得思考的。不過，一個普通上班族，也能從這個案例得到什麼啟發嗎？
我猜啦，其實很多辦公室裡也有「廢棄物」啊，只是不是實體的。像很多重複的工作流程、重複的資訊、重複的會議，這些都是可以被「鑽石化」的潛力。
你的意思是，把那些看似沒用的時間或資料，透過一種「低溫」的方式，也就是用新的方法或工具重新組合，變成能解決問題的「高價值應用」？這點其實很有意思。
對啊，或者像很多數據中心一樣，常常有部門之間的「熱點」衝突，資訊不透明導致的內耗。是不是也能找到一個「鑽石塗層」，來減少這種摩擦，讓整個組織運作更有效率？
這麼一說，的確。很多時候我們可能都低估了身邊那些看似「廢棄」的潛力。這家 HexSeed 的案例，好像也提醒了我們，那些被我們忽略的邊角料，或許才是真正的高價值所在。